Narrator: AFTER SIX SEASONS
AND MORE THAN $65 MILLION
INVESTED IN THE TANK SO FAR,
"SHARK TANK" HAS INSPIRED
A NATION TO DREAM BIG...
[ ENGINE REVS ]
Greiner: WOW.
WE'RE WITNESSING
THE AGE OF UNMANNED FLIGHT.
WE'RE RAISING THE NEXT
GENERATION OF ENTREPRENEURS.
SO WHO'S READY
TO LIGHT THE WORLD ON FIRE?
Narrator: ...AND MADE
ENTREPRENEURS OUR NEW HEROES.
THIS IS MY IDEA. I WANT TO MAKE
THIS INTO SOMETHING BIG.
THAT'S THE AMERICAN DREAM.
WE'VE BEEN BUILDING ROBOTS
SINCE WE WERE
IN MIDDLE SCHOOL.
THE BEST PRODUCT
OF SEASON 7 SO FAR.
AMERICA,
YOU ARE WELCOME!
[ LAUGHS ]
Narrator: BUT FIRST,
THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST WOW THE SHARKS
WITH THEIR INGENUITY...
GET THAT TWIST AND RUN.
THE MORE YOU GET THE
BOARD TWISTING, THE MORE
YOU'RE GONNA FEEL IT.
Woman: THERE YOU GO!
GET LOW! GET LOW!
BOOM!
[ LAUGHTER ]
WHOO!
Narrator: ...HARD WORK...
I'M THE DUDE WHO'S GOT
FIRE IN HIS BELLY
LIKE YOU HAVE NEVER SEEN!
Narrator:
...AND DETERMINATION.
THIS IS MY PASSION.
THIS IS MY DESTINY.
I'M SUPPOSED TO BE HERE.
I CAN DO THIS.
YOU'VE GOT TO GIVE UP
THIS CRYING STUFF.
THE MINUTE A WOMAN CRIES,
YOU'RE GIVING AWAY YOUR POWER.
Narrator: ONLY IN THE TANK CAN
A SHARK'S BITE MAKE YOU BLEED...
I WOULD JUST FEEL STUPID
INVESTING IN THIS.
I'M SORRY.
COULD YOU REPEAT THAT?
YOU CAN'T COME IN HERE
NOT KNOWING YOUR NUMBERS.
THIS IS THE SHARK TANK.
WE'RE GONNA KILL YOU.
Narrator:
...OR CHANGE YOUR LIFE FOREVER.
WHOO-HOO!
I MAKE MILLIONAIRES.
IT'S WHAT I DO.
I WANT YOU IN MY CORNER.
YOU'RE THE REAL DEAL.
I'M GONNA CREATE SUCCESS
NO MATTER WHAT.
GIVE US AN OFFER!
AHH!
Narrator: AND THIS SEASON,
NEW, CUTTING-EDGE SHARKS
WILL CHANGE THE GAME --
BILLIONAIRE SILICON VALLEY TITAN
CHRIS SACCA...
IF CHRIS IS WILLING TO ACCEPT
MY HAND BACK IN --
LOOK,
YOU'RE WILLING TO SHARE
BECAUSE YOU'RE SWIMMING
IN MY WAKE.
NO, THAT'S NOT --
YOU'RE RIDING MY COATTAILS.
YOU KNOW
WHAT I COULD BRING.
...MUSIC INDUSTRY PIONEER,
TECH INVESTOR,
AND BRANDING EXPERT
TROY CARTER....
THERE'S ANOTHER KID IN
THE GARAGE THAT WANTS
TO EAT YOUR LUNCH.
I JUST
DON'T SEE THAT HAPPENING.
AND I DON'T SEE MY INVESTMENT
HAPPENING. I'M OUT.
Narrator: ...AND TONIGHT,
PROLIFIC INVESTOR
AND VENTURE CAPITALIST
ASHTON KUTCHER JOINS THE TANK.
LET'S TALK ABOUT DEMAND.
IF YOU HAVE REAL DEMAND,
YOU CAN'T KEEP THE PRODUCT
ON SHELVES.
YOU HAVE MANUFACTURING
CONSTRAINT.
THAT'S DEMAND.
Narrator: IT'S A BRAND-NEW
SEASON OF "SHARK TANK."
YOU'RE NOT LISTENING.
NO, YOU'RE NOT LISTENING.
I DON'T CARE, MARK!
YOU'RE BELITTLING PEOPLE,
AND THAT'S NOT OKAY.
NO, I'M NOT!
DON'T GIVE ME THAT BULL.
I WANT AN ANSWER.
SHE GAVE YOU AN ANSWER!
KIND OF SPICY, RIGHT?
Narrator: AND IT ALL STARTS...
NOW.
LET'S DO THIS.
Narrator: FIRST INTO
THE TANK IS ONE DAD'S SOLUTION
TO MAKE BABIES'
FEEDING TIME EASIER.
♪♪
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS MARTIN HILL.
AND I AM THE OWNER AND CREATOR
OF THE BEEBO.
I AM SEEKING
A $200,000 INVESTMENT
IN EXCHANGE FOR A 20%
EQUITY STAKE IN MY COMPANY.
PARENTS HAVE BEEN BOTTLE-FEEDING
THEIR BABIES THE SAME WAY
FOR OVER 150 YEARS -- BABY IN
ONE HAND, BOTTLE IN THE OTHER.
I HAVE CREATED A PRODUCT
THAT ENHANCES THE WAY
PARENTS BOTTLE-FEED,
TAKING THIS PRECIOUS MOMENT
AND MAKING IT BETTER.
I AM VERY PROUD
TO INTRODUCE YOU TO THE BEEBO --
A BETTER WAY TO BOTTLE-FEED.
[ GREINER CHUCKLES ]
OH...MY...GOD.
[ LAUGHTER ]
O'Leary: OH, YEAH.
Hill: THE BEEBO
IS PEDIATRICIAN-APPROVED
AND EASY TO USE.
YOU SIMPLY PLACE THE BEEBO
OVER EITHER SHOULDER...
INSERT YOUR BABY'S BOTTLE...
AND THEN ROTATE
TO THE DESIRED FEEDING ANGLE.
HMM.
YOU CAN EVEN ROTATE THE BOTTLE
UP AND OUT OF THE WAY
FOR BURPING OR PLAYTIME.
THE BEEBO FREES UP A HAND
DURING FEEDING,
ALLOWING YOU
TO READ TO YOUR BABY,
CARESS YOUR BABY, EVEN ENJOY
FAMILY MEALS TOGETHER.
SO, SHARKS, WHO WANTS TO JOIN ME
IN GIVING PARENTS AND BABIES
THAT HELPING HAND
THEY NEED AND DESERVE?
Greiner: AH.
I'VE GOT SAMPLES FOR YOU.
ASHTON, ISN'T YOUR BABY HERE?
WHY DON'T YOU GO GRAB HER?
I'M PRETTY SURE MY BABY'S
A "NOT ON-CAMERA" BABY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'M FAIRLY CERTAIN THAT MY BABY
ISN'T PART OF THE EQUATION.
OH, THANK YOU. OH, OH,
LET ME GRAB ONE FOR LORI.
YOU'RE VERY WELCOME.
SHE HAS A HARD TIME REACHING.
THANK YOU.
IF YOU JUST HOLD ON
TO THEM FOR ONE SECOND,
I'LL SHOW YOU THE -- THE BEST,
EASIEST WAY TO USE THEM.
SOME PEOPLE LIKE TO PUT IT
A LITTLE BIT LOW...
[ LAUGHS ]
...BECAUSE OF
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
[ CHUCKLES ] SO...
Kutcher: HOW MANY
DIFFERENT KINDS OF BOTTLES
CAN YOU USE FOR THIS?
LIKE, CERTAIN BABIES
LOVE THE DR. BROWN'S.
MM-HMM.
SOME LIKE THOSE COMOTOMOS.
MAN,
YOU KNOW YOUR BOTTLES.
HEY, LISTEN. I'M ON --
I'M ON -- I'M ON DAD DUTY.
SO, THIS IS MADE
OUT OF A VERY SOFT SKIN
SO THAT IT'S WATERTIGHT,
FLEXIBLE FOAM.
MARTIN, LET ME --
LET ME HAVE THE KID.
IT'S BASICALLY
AN EXTRA HAND.
CARLOS OR BOB?
YEAH, I'LL GO WITH THIS.
YOU KNOW.
[ LAUGHTER ]
ASHTON,
YOU'RE A FATHER RIGHT NOW.
WHY DON'T YOU
CHECK THIS OUT?
I-I...
YEAH, THAT'S WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT.
GAME ON.
YOU LOOK GOOD.
YOU'RE A LITTLE...
[ SIGHS ]
[ LAUGHS ]
I LIKE IT.
[ SIGHS ]
GET IT.
THERE WE GO.
AND THIS IS FOR NEXT TIME
WHEN YOU HAVE TWINS.
[ LAUGHS ]
Hill: THERE YOU GO.
THERE WE GO.
Hill: WE DO GET --
DOUBLE DUTY.
WE DO GET A LOT OF PEOPLE
WITH TWINS BUYING THIS.
MARTIN, HOW DID YOU COME UP
WITH THIS?
I'M AN ELECTRICAL ENGINEER
BY TRADE.
MY LITTLE BOY, JACOB,
HE -- HE WENT THROUGH A PHASE
OF REALLY STRUGGLING
WITH HIS BOTTLE,
SO I CAME UP WITH THIS IDEA
BECAUSE HE WAS HIS MOST RELAXED
WHEN I WAS READING A BOOK
TO HIM.
I MADE MY PROTOTYPE
IN MY GARAGE,
I STARTED USING IT, AND EVERY
TIME HE'D SUCK HIS BOTTLE DRY.
HOW MUCH HAVE YOU SOLD?
WE'VE SOLD ABOUT $20,000 WORTH
SINCE FEBRUARY.
AND HOW MUCH DOES EACH UNIT SELL
FOR, AND WHAT DO THEY COST YOU?
WHAT IS YOUR COST PER UNIT?
SURE, THE MSRP IS $39.95,
AND THE MANUFACTURED COST
PER GOODS SO FAR PER UNIT TO ME
IS $10.86.
SO, IN FEBRUARY,
WE ONLY SOLD ABOUT $1,800.
IN MARCH,
WE MORE THAN DOUBLED THAT.
WE ARE STARTING TO GET KIND OF
INUNDATED WITH BUYERS RIGHT NOW.
WE'VE BEEN CONTACTED
BY SOME BIG-BOX RETAIL.
AND YOU HAVE NOTHING
IN RETAIL NOW?
NO, NOTHING.
CAN I SEE A PACKAGE,
MARTIN?
YEAH, SURE.
Greiner: DID YOU DO
ALL OF THE PACKAGING YOURSELF --
THE DESIGNING
OF THE PACKAGING?
I HAD A LOT OF SAY IN IT.
IT DOESN'T REALLY TELL YOU
WHAT IT IS.
IT'S HARD.
I MEAN, I THINK YOU'D STRUGGLE
WITH THIS PACKAGING IN RETAIL.
THAT'S PART OF THE FUNDING.
YOU KNOW, WE'RE GONNA DO
A WHOLE BRAND REFRESH.
O'Leary: IS YOUR PATENT
ISSUED RIGHT NOW?
THE UTILITY PATENT
IS FULLY ISSUED.
WHY DID YOU NAME IT "BEEBO"?
[ CHUCKLES ]
SO, WHEN I INVENTED
MY FIRST PROTOTYPE,
I USED TO CALL IT "THE BOOBY."
OH, "THE BOOBY." [ LAUGHS ]
BOOBY -- I LIKE BOOBY --
I LIKE BOOBY BETTER.
SO, THAT GOT SHOT DOWN
BY MY WIFE.
I BET.
[ Laughing ] YEAH.
IT'S A GOOD NAME.
[ LAUGHS ]
IT IS. I THOUGHT SO, TOO.
O'Leary: I-I LIKE THIS PRODUCT.
IT'S VERY SIMPLE.
THE MESSAGING IS WEAK
ON THE RETAIL PACKAGE,
BUT I THINK THE UTILITY OF IT
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE.
IN MY BABY-FEEDING DAYS,
I REALLY HAD A LOT OF TROUBLE
WITH THE WHOLE DEAL
WITH THE BOTTLE.
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $200,000
FOR 33.3%.
I THINK THE PRODUCT
IN RETAIL
WILL BE SUCCESSFUL
AFTER BEING REPACKAGED.
YOU'RE GONNA NEED MORE CASH.
BUT I LIKE IT.
IT'S -- THAT'S A VERY SIMPLE
DEAL, STRAIGHT UP.
I'LL TAKE 1/3 OF THE BUSINESS.
I'LL GIVE YOU $200,000.
Kutcher: HOW MUCH OF YOUR OWN
MONEY HAVE YOU INVESTED IN THIS,
AND WHAT ARE YOUR PROJECTIONS
ON SALES FOR THE NEXT YEAR?
SO, WE'VE INVESTED
ABOUT $180,000 FROM DAY ONE.
AND YOUR PROJECTIONS
OVER THE NEXT YEAR?
OKAY, SO, MY GOAL FOR YEAR ONE
IS 14,000 UNITS.
THE REASON WHY THAT'S THERE
IS BECAUSE OF
MANUFACTURING CONSTRAINTS.
RIGHT NOW, WE ONLY HAVE
ONE SET OF MOLDS.
AND THEN NEXT YEAR,
MY GOAL IS TO START RAMPING UP
MORE INTO BIG-BOX RETAIL.
MARTIN, LOOK, YOU'VE DONE
AN AMAZING JOB WITH IT.
I ADMIRE THE FACT
THAT YOU PUT UP $180,000
TO START THIS BUSINESS.
I LOVE PEOPLE
THAT ARE ALL-IN.
YEP.
IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME
SINCE I'VE HAD A BABY,
AND I HAD EVERY PROBLEM
YOU CAN IMAGINE
AND FOUND WAYS TO SOLVE IT,
YOU KNOW?
YEAH.
I NEVER REMEMBER THIS
BEING A PROBLEM FOR ME.
I JUST DON'T SEE THE PAIN.
I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
♪♪
YOU KNOW, I THINK --
I THINK IT'S A GREAT PRODUCT.
BUT FROM MY END,
IT WOULDN'T COME TO MY MIND
TO THINK THAT I'D NEED A --
AN ADDITIONAL TOOL, RIGHT?
EVEN IF IT'S MESSY,
IN MY CASE, OR...
YEAH.
...YOU KNOW,
FIDGETY OR WHATEVER,
I STILL WOULDN'T
THINK THAT,
"OKAY, I NEED TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM."
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
THANKS.
I THINK WHAT YOU'VE BUILT HERE
IS REALLY COOL.
ONE OF MY FAVORITE THINGS TO DO
IS ACTUALLY FEED HER
AND HAVE THAT MOMENT.
YEAH.
BUT I THINK MY EXPERTISE
WOULD BE MORE VALUABLE TO YOU
LATER DOWN THE ROAD
WHEN YOU NEED TO REALLY PUSH
A MARKETING CAMPAIGN.
I THINK I COULD HELP YOU
DO A LOT OF THOSE THINGS.
I-I -- FRANKLY, WHEN IT COMES
TO MANUFACTURING HARD GOODS,
GETTING THEM DONE
AT THE RIGHT PRICE POINT,
I DON'T THINK I'M GONNA BE
VERY HELPFUL THERE.
OKAY.
SO, FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
SO, I WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE AN OFFER.
$200,000...AT 30%.
ASHTON,
I'D LIKE YOU TO PARTICIPATE
BECAUSE I DO THINK
AS A NEW DAD
AND WITH ALL OF YOUR SOCIAL
AND MARKETING CONNECTIONS,
ET CETERA -- I HAVE THE END
OF ALL THE RETAIL,
AND BEING ABLE TO
ALSO MANUFACTURE THIS,
I THINK,
AT A MUCH BETTER PRICE.
YEAH.
I ALSO AM AN EXPERT
AT PACKAGING
AND MAKING THINGS JUST
FLY OFF THE SHELF REALLY FAST.
I KNOW YOU ARE, YEAH.
THAT'S ONE OF MY SWEET SPOTS.
SO...I WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE YOU THAT OFFER.
I WOULD LIKE YOU
TO COME IN WITH ME, ASHTON.
♪♪
I WOULD SPLIT THAT DEAL
WITH YOU,
$100,000,
$100,000 AND 30%...
Greiner: $100,000?
...15%, 15%.
15%, 15%.
OKAY.
THERE YOU GO.
SO YOU GOT TWO OFFERS.
♪♪
THERE WAS ACTUALLY TWO PEOPLE
THAT I HAD MY EYE ON
WHEN I WALKED IN HERE.
LORI AND ASHTON,
YOU WERE THE TWO.
I WOULD LOVE TO BLOW THIS UP
WORLDWIDE WITH YOU GUYS.
WHOO-HOO!
SO IS THAT A YES?
ARE YOU TAKING THE DEAL?
ABSOLUTELY.
MATCH MADE IN HEAVEN.
[ LAUGHS ]
NICE!
THANKS, MAN.
THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE IT. THIS WILL BE FUN.
CONGRATS ON THE LITTLE ONE.
YEAH.
Greiner: THAT'S AWESOME.
THANK YOU.
Herjavec: CONGRATS, MARTIN.
THANKS.
Greiner: I LOVE IT.
CONGRATS, ASHTON.
CONGRATS.
FIRST "SHARK TANK" DEAL.
ASHTON, FIRST DEAL. WHOO!
FIRST DEAL!
WHOO!
[ LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
Narrator:
NEXT UP IS A UNIQUE INNOVATION
IN PERSONAL TRANSPORTATION.
♪♪
I'M PETER TREADWAY, AND I'M
FROM LOS ANGELES, CALIFORNIA.
MY COMPANY IS ACTON.
I AM HERE SEEKING $1 MILLION IN
EXCHANGE FOR 3.5% OF MY COMPANY.
WOW.
SHARKS, WE KNOW TRANSPORTATION
IS DESTINED TO CHANGE.
AT ACTON,
WE DESIGN AND MANUFACTURE
WEARABLE TRANSPORTATION --
ROCKET SKATES.
ROCKET SKATES ARE THE WORLD'S
SMALLEST ELECTRIC VEHICLE.
STEP INTO
A PAIR OF ROCKET SKATES,
AND YOU CAN GO ANYWHERE
AT ANYTIME.
YOU SIMPLY PRESS DOWN ON YOUR
HEEL TO ACTIVATE THE MOTORS,
AND THEN YOU PUSH OFF
TO GLIDE ALONG.
ROCKET SKATES WILL TAKE YOU
UP TO 10 MILES AN HOUR.
THEY'LL KEEP YOU GOING
FOR 10 MILES ON A SINGLE CHARGE.
HMM.
THEY COMMUNICATE WIRELESSLY
WITH EACH OTHER
SO THAT
THEY MAINTAIN THE SAME SPEEDS,
AND THEY ARE
COMPLETELY CONTROLLED
BY YOUR FEET --
NO REMOTE WHATSOEVER.
WE'VE BEEN PROMISED THIS FUTURE
FOR GENERATIONS.
AND NOW, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
YOUR FUTURE HAS ARRIVED.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THE ELECTRIC BOOGALOO
IS BACK.
[ GREINER LAUGHS ]
♪♪
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ CHUCKLES ]
CAN WE TRY THEM?
YES, YOU MAY.
OH, MY GOSH.
[ CHUCKLES ]
ASHTON, COME ON.
LET'S TRY THEM.
[ LAUGHS ]
OH, MAN.
HERE, LET ME GET YOU --
LET ME GET YOU SET UP.
IS IT -- IS IT LIKE A SEGWAY
ON YOUR FEET?
YOU KNOW, SOME PEOPLE
DESCRIBE IT THAT WAY.
LET'S PUT YOUR RIGHT FOOT
IN THERE.
Herjavec: ANY SHOE, RIGHT?
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
A SOFT SOLE, A HARD SOLE?
WELL, THAT'S RIGHT,
AND YOU CAN'T WEAR HEELS.
[ LAUGHS ]
BUT THEY ARE PRETTY GOOD
WITH ANY OTHER TYPE OF SHOES.
O'Leary:
THIS IS GONNA END BADLY.
WHERE'S MY CAMERA?
Treadway: SO,
I HAVE THEM ON BEGINNER MODE.
AND ONCE YOU PUSH OFF,
THE MOTORS WILL KICK IN.
THERE THEY ARE.
Herjavec: OH.
THIS IS --
BOY, YOU REALLY GOT THIS.
YEAH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Herjavec: SHUT UP, ASHTON.
ONE LESS SHARK!
[ LAUGHTER ]
WATCH THE FISH TANK!
Herjavec:
ALL RIGHT, YOUR TURN.
I'M GOOD. I'M GOOD.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Treadway: WONDERFUL.
Greiner:
OH, THERE YOU GO.
[ CHUCKLES ]
WHOA, WHOA!
OOH!
LEAN FORWARD,
LEAN FORWARD.
PRIME TIME,
NATIONAL TV -- BOZO.
Herjavec: ALL RIGHT, IT'S
KIND OF COOL ONCE YOU GET GOING.
IT'S HARDER
THAN IT LOOKS.
IT -- IT LOOKS HARD!
O'Leary: SO, PETER, OBVIOUSLY,
THERE'S A LEARNING CURVE,
AND YOU'VE GONE THROUGH
MANY PEOPLE TRYING THESE OUT.
HOW LONG DO YOU THINK
IT'S GONNA TAKE
FOR SOMEBODY
TO GET PROFICIENT
WHERE THEY DON'T
NEED TO BE HELD UP
AND LOOK LIKE THEY'RE ON THEIR
WAY TO THE RETIREMENT HOME?
Treadway: WELL, I MEAN --
NOBODY HELD ME!
YEAH.
MOST OF OUR CUSTOMERS
ARE COLLEGE STUDENTS
AND -- AND YOUNGER.
AND FOR MOST OF THEM,
THEY JUST GET ON
AND START RIDING RIGHT AWAY.
PETER, HOW MUCH ARE THEY?
HOW MUCH DO YOU SELL THEM FOR?
THESE ARE $499, $599,
AND $699, SO --
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN PRICES?
THE DIFFERENCE IS RANGE.
SO, WE HAVE A 6-, 8-,
AND 10-MILE VERSION.
AND HOW MUCH DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE THEM?
OUR COST STRUCTURE
IS AROUND, SAY, 40%.
SO IT COSTS YOU $200 TO MAKE
THE $500 -- THE $499 VERSION?
SOMEWHERE AROUND THERE.
WAS THIS --
WHY ARE YOU BEING
SO VARIABLE ABOUT IT?
WELL, A LOT OF PEOPLE
WATCH THIS SHOW.
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR INVESTORS.
YEAH, I'M -- IT'S A PRETTY --
IT'S A PRETTY ACCURATE ANSWER.
PETER, ARE PEOPLE
BUYING THEM AS A TOY?
PEOPLE ARE BUYING THEM
MOSTLY FOR FUN,
BUT WE GET VIDEOS ALL THE TIME
FROM OUR CUSTOMERS
WHO ARE USING THEM
TO ACTUALLY GET TO THE TRAIN,
TO ACTUALLY GO TO WORK.
Cuban: YEAH,
IF YOU'RE ON A CAMPUS --
I MEAN, I USED TO
ROLLER-SKATE AROUND INDIANA.
I MEAN, THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN BADASS.
Herjavec: OF COURSE,
YOU'RE DEFINITELY ON A TRAIN --
DO YOU HAVE A PATENT
ON THIS?
TWO UTILITY PATENTS,
FOUR DESIGN PATENTS,
AND THEN WE HAVE 16 PATENTS
THAT ARE PENDING RIGHT NOW.
Herjavec: PETER,
A $30 MILLION VALUATION.
HOW IS THIS
A $100-MILLION BUSINESS?
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
LAST YEAR, WE HAD
A MILLION AND A HALF IN SALES,
WHICH WAS PRETTY MUCH
OUR FIRST REAL YEAR OF SALES.
THIS YEAR,
WE'RE UP TO $2 MILLION SO FAR.
WHAT CHANNELS?
OUR WEBSITE,
AND WE HAVE SPENT
THE FIRST HALF OF THIS YEAR
TALKING WITH A LOT OF BIG-BOX
STORES, PEOPLE LIKE TARGET.
YOU'RE HOPING TO SELL THIS
AT $500 IN A TARGET?
YES.
BUT WE DO HAVE
A-A LESS-EXPENSIVE VERSION.
WE -- THAT WAS --
PETER, BASED ON THE TRAJECTORY
YOU'VE SEEN SO FAR,
WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU'LL NET
THIS YEAR?
UH, $10 MILLION.
$10 MILLION?
Herjavec: $10 MILLION?
YES.
THAT'S A HELL OF A RAMP.
DO YOU HAVE ENOUGH MONEY
TO BUILD THE INVENTORY
TO PUT INTO RETAIL
TO GET THAT NUMBER?
AND CAN YOU BUILD THAT MUCH?
Treadway: YES.
WE'RE TALKING WITH
A-A COUPLE OF NEW FACTORIES.
BUT THE FACTORIES THAT
WE'RE WORKING WITH AT THE MOMENT
ARE ABLE TO DO
HUNDREDS OF THEM EVERY DAY,
SO WE'RE GETTING THAT STARTED
IN THE NEXT COUPLE --
Greiner: HOW MANY A MONTH?
DO YOU KNOW
HOW MANY THOUSAND A MONTH?
OH,
I DON'T KNOW OFFHAND.
Kutcher: WHAT HAS
YOUR FINANCING BEEN TO DATE?
WE'VE HAD
A $2 MILLION SEED ROUND,
AND WE'VE JUST CLOSED THE FIRST
TRENCH OF OUR "A" ROUND,
WHICH WAS $2 1/2 MILLION,
SO WE'RE --
AN ADDITIONAL
$2 1/2 MILLION?
THAT'S RIGHT.
WHAT WAS THE VALUE OF THAT?
$2 1/2 MILLION?
UM, UH...
FORGIVE ME --
THE NUMBERS ARE A LITTLE JUMBLED
IN MY HEAD RIGHT NOW,
BUT IT WAS, YOU KNOW, 20...
SOMEWHERE AROUND 20 --
$20 MILLION PRE-MONEY
VALUATION, AND ANOTHER
$2 1/2 MILLION WENT IN?
SOMEWHERE AROUND --
SOMEWHERE AROUND THERE.
Cuban: PETER, WHAT -- WHAT'S
YOUR MONTHLY BURN RIGHT NOW,
AND WHAT'S
YOUR BREAK-EVEN POINT?
THE BREAK-EVEN POINT
IS HAPPENING AS WE SPEAK,
AND WE'RE -- WE'RE AT
ABOUT 100 GRAND A MONTH.
Herjavec: SO, PETER,
I LOVE THE TECHNOLOGY.
YOU KNOW, I'VE ALWAYS THOUGHT
THIS IS SUCH A HUGE MARKET,
ESPECIALLY FOR COMMUTERS.
HERE'S WHAT I DON'T LIKE.
YOU'VE RAISED, WHAT, TWO ROUNDS?
YES, TWO ROUNDS.
YOU KNOW, YOU'VE PRICED IN
A $28 MILLION VALUATION.
YOU NEED INCREDIBLE EXECUTIONAL
EXCELLENCE ALL ALONG THE PATH...
MM-HMM.
...FOR ME AT 3 1/2%
TO GET A GREAT RETURN.
SO THE ONLY WAY
I'LL EVER MAKE MONEY
IS IF YOU HIT IT
OUT OF THE BALLPARK.
WELL, LET'S DO THAT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GOOD ANSWER.
I'M HOLDING THE BAT OUT.
THIS IS GOING OUT.
I'M A BELIEVER. I-I GET IT.
IT'S GOING OUT.
I'LL DEFINITELY BUY THEM,
BUT, YOU KNOW, HONESTLY,
YOU'RE NOT GONNA LOWER
YOUR VALUE BY HALF.
I JUST KNOW THAT. YOU CAME HERE
WITH A VERY SPECIFIC VALUE.
OBVIOUSLY,
WE HAVE OTHER INVESTORS,
AND WE CAN'T, YOU KNOW,
THROW THE VALUATION AROUND
TOO MUCH.
BUT I CAME HERE TO MAKE A DEAL,
SO THAT IS --
I MEAN,
I'M NOT HERE BY MISTAKE.
THIS IS A GREAT MOMENT FOR ME
AND FOR OUR COMPANY.
I-IT'S FUN.
3 1/2% AT A $28 MILLION
VALUATION ISN'T FUN FOR ME.
I'M OUT.
♪♪
I'M IN THE PLACE WHERE
A MILLION DOLLARS FOR 3 1/2%
DOESN'T SHOW ME
THE LOVE.
IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE ME FEEL AS
WONDERFUL AS I KNOW I REALLY AM.
SO HOW WONDERFUL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO FEEL?
[ LAUGHS ]
NO, BUT IT'S JUST --
I-I'LL MAKE THIS --
I'LL MAKE THIS EVEN SIMPLER
BECAUSE YOU ARE
JUST WONDERFUL...
THANK YOU.
...AND I THINK YOU HAVE
SOME REAL INTEREST HERE,
AND I THINK THAT AT THE --
IF YOUR PRICE IS RIGHT,
YOU MAY BE IN.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S A PRICE
THAT'S RIGHT THAT GETS ME IN.
I THINK YOU'RE INSPIRING
BECAUSE I THINK YOU DREAM BIG,
AND I THINK THAT
YOU SEE THE WORLD DIFFERENTLY
THAN OTHER PEOPLE SEE IT.
THANK YOU.
I AGREE WITH YOU
THAT THIS TRANSPORTATION SHIFT
IS EMERGING RIGHT NOW,
AND IT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF OTHER
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN YOUR SPACE
THAT ARE TRYING TO DO
THEIR VARIOUS VERSIONS OF IT.
WHEN I WATCHED YOU GUYS
COME IN --
AND YOU GUYS
ARE THE EXPERTS --
I DIDN'T GO,
"MAN, I WANT TO GET ON THOSE."
I THINK THE SKATES --
THEY'RE GOOD.
I THINK THAT THEY'RE A WAYS AWAY
FROM BEING MASS-CONSUMER.
I THINK I WOULD BE
FAR MORE INTERESTED
IF I LOOKED AT THE PRODUCT
AND WENT,
"MAN,
I WANT TO GET ON THOSE."
AND FOR ME
TO REALLY GET BEHIND SOMETHING,
I'VE GOT TO
LOVE THE PRODUCT.
SO I'M GONNA --
I'M GONNA STEP OUT.
Greiner: I WILL SAY,
I LOVE INVENTION.
OBVIOUSLY, BEING AN
INVENTOR, MADE A LOT
OF PRODUCTS OVER THE YEARS.
I THINK IT'S VERY CLEVER,
BUT WHAT BOTHERS ME
A LITTLE BIT IS,
I ALMOST FEEL LIKE
YOU CAME IN HERE
FEELING LIKE FOR SURE
YOU WERE GONNA GET SOMETHING,
SO YOU DIDN'T
HAVE TO TRY TOO HARD.
OR YOU HAVE
ALL YOUR OTHER SEED ROUNDS,
SO YOU DON'T
NEED TO TRY TOO HARD.
AND I'M NOT THE ONE TO SIT HERE
AND SAY THIS KIND OF THING.
MY GUT TELLS ME
THAT YOU'RE NOT REALLY
DYING FOR A DEAL HERE TODAY.
♪♪
Narrator:
TWO SHARKS ARE OUT,
AND LORI IS SKEPTICAL
ABOUT PETER'S MOTIVATION
TO MAKE A DEAL
FOR HIS ELECTRIC-POWERED SKATE
COMPANY, ACTON ROCKET SKATES.
Greiner:
MY GUT TELLS ME
THAT YOU'RE NOT REALLY
DYING FOR A DEAL HERE TODAY.
I MEAN,
I AM HERE TO MAKE A DEAL.
I'VE -- I'VE PRESENTED
MY NUMBERS THAT --
THAT WE'D LIKE TO SEE,
BUT I'M CAPABLE OF NEGOTIATING.
I'M OUT.
♪♪
Cuban:
WELL, I-I'LL GO NEXT.
I THINK YOU'RE HERE FOR A DEAL.
I-I LIKE WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
I AGREE
THAT PERSONAL TRANSPORTATION
IS JUST GOING TO EXPLODE.
I DON'T THINK
THERE'S GONNA BE ANYTHING
THAT KEEPS PEOPLE
FROM TRYING TO BE MORE EFFICIENT
AND FASTER IN HOW THEY GO FROM
PLACE TO PLACE ON THEIR OWN.
BUT WHEN I ASKED YOU
ABOUT THE NUMBERS,
YOU WERE ALL OVER THE MAP
WITH YOUR PRESENTATION.
I DON'T THINK IT WAS CONCISE
ENOUGH FOR ME TO FEEL CONFIDENT.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
UNDERSTOOD.
SO, ONE SHARK LEFT.
O'Leary: I LOOK AT
THE RISK/RETURN ON THIS DEAL.
HIGH RISK, AND THE ONLY WAY
I GET A GREAT RETURN
IS IF YOU
ABSOLUTELY BLOW IT OUT.
HMM.
AND I THINK YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
SOME BUMPS ALONG THE ROAD.
I'M NOT CONVINCED YOU'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO SHIP $10 MILLION
WORTH OF THESE THIS YEAR.
WE'RE -- WE'RE -- WE ARE --
BUT IT DOESN'T MATTER
BECAUSE THERE'S NO WAY ON EARTH
I'D GIVE YOU
A MILLION DOLLARS AT 3 1/2%.
IT'S A LOT --
IT'S A LOT OF DOUGH.
I THINK YOU'VE ASKED
FOR TOO MUCH IN TERMS
OF WHAT IT'S WORTH TODAY.
I WOULD DO A MILLION BUCKS
FOR 15%.
UH...
WELL, I MEAN, THAT'S -- THAT'S
A BIG JUMP FROM WHERE I AM.
OH, YES, IT IS.
UM, WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT,
SAY...
[ SIGHS ]
...6% FOR A MILLION?
THAT CUTS HIS VALUATION
IN HALF ALMOST.
I'D HAVE TO BE INCENTIVISED
AT A MUCH, MUCH HIGHER...
EQUITY POSITION
TO TAKE ON THE RISK.
I-I WOULD LOVE TO OFFER YOU
SOMETHING HERE.
I CAN GO A LITTLE HIGHER THAN --
THAN 6%,
BUT YOU HAVEN'T COME DOWN
FROM 15%.
NO, BECAUSE
THE WAY I FEEL IT IS,
IF I PUT THE MILLION BUCKS IN
AT 15%,
I FEEL THAT I'LL BE DILUTED DOWN
TO -- WHO KNOWS? --
7 1/2% BY THE TIME
YOU'RE FINISHED RAISING MONEY.
I-I -- IT'S TOO HIGH FOR --
FOR WHAT WE WANT TO DO.
NOT FOR ME.
IT MAKES SENSE FOR ME.
[ CUBAN LAUGHS ]
WHAT'S YOUR COUNTER?
7%.
HE JUST WENT TO 7%.
HE CUT HIS VALUATION IN HALF.
I DON'T CARE, MARK!
[ GROANS ]
I-I WISH I COULD GO HIGHER
THAN THAT, BUT I -- YOU KNOW,
I DO HAVE THE -- THE OTHER
INVESTORS TO CONSIDER.
I FEEL GOOD
ABOUT THE DEAL.
THE VALUE OUT OF BEING ON
"SHARK TANK" AND GETTING A DEAL
IS GEOMETRIC BECAUSE
YOU STAY ON "SHARK TANK."
YOU STAY
ON THE PLATFORM.
WHAT YOU MAY GET FROM THIS
IS A POP IN ONLINE SALES,
BUT THEN YOU'RE GONNA DRIFT OFF
INTO OBLIVION
BECAUSE NOBODY STEPPED UP
TO THE PLATE ON YOUR VALUATION.
THAT'S WHAT REALLY
HAPPENED HERE, PETER.
YOU COULDN'T EVEN GET INTERESTED
PARTIES THAT MAY HAVE LIKED THIS
TO GIVE YOU A MILLION BUCKS
AT 3 1/2%.
SO MY JOB IS TO MAKE YOU
PAY THE REAL PRICE
FOR GETTING THIS
ELUSIVE PLATFORM ON YOUR SIDE.
WELL, I WANT TO COUNTER.
8%.
I THREW YOU A BONE
BECAUSE I'M A GENEROUS MAN.
I TOLD YOU
I HAD NO FLEXIBILITY.
IT WAS AN OFFER --
MY ONLY OFFER --
AND I STRONGLY RECOMMEND
YOU TAKE IT.
I WANT 15%.
YES OR NO?
WELL...
♪♪
...I'M GOING TO HAVE TO SAY NO,
THEN.
THEN YOU'RE DEAD TO ME.
SKATE OUT OF HERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
Greiner: GOOD LUCK, PETER.
Cuban: GOOD LUCK.
WE'LL BE LOOKING FORWARD TO IT.
REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
YOU MADE
A HUGE MISTAKE.
BYE-BYE. THANK YOU.
Herjavec: I THOUGHT
HE HAD WAY MORE FLEXIBILITY
THAN I EVER THOUGHT HE WOULD.
UH-HUH.
I GAVE HIM RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE RANGE OF WHAT IT'S WORTH.
NO, YOU GAVE HIM WELL BELOW
THE RANGE OF WHAT IT'S WORTH.
THAT'S 4 BELOW.
LOOK, I HAVE TO BE PAID
FOR THE RISK I'M TAKING
BECAUSE I THINK
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN HERE IS,
THIS GUY IS NOT GONNA GET
ANYWHERE NEAR
THE SALES HE THOUGHT 'CAUSE
THE PRODUCT'S TOO EXPENSIVE.
I AGREE. I AGREE.
WE'LL FIND OUT.
I THINK HE'S GONNA HAVE
A HARDER TIME THAN HE THINKS.
♪♪
Corcoran: I'M HERE AT THE FANCY
FOOD SHOW TODAY IN NEW YORK CITY
BECAUSE TWO OF MY INVESTMENTS,
SCRATCH & GRAIN AND PIPCORN,
ARE HERE
TO EXHIBIT THEIR PRODUCT.
GORGEOUS!
THE FANCY FOOD SHOW
IS THE LARGEST TRADE SHOW
FOR SPECIALTY FOODS
IN NORTH AMERICA.
ALL THE BIG RETAILERS ARE HERE.
YOU'VE GOT WHOLE FOODS,
COSTCO, TRADER JOE'S,
AND WE WANT TO BE
ON THEIR SHELVES.
DO YOU GUYS WANT
SOME INFORMATION TO
TAKE WITH YOU, TOO?
YEAH,
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
OUR GOAL TODAY IS TO CONNECT
WITH POTENTIAL BUYERS.
AND IF THEY LIKE WHAT
THEY TASTE, WE GET ORDERS.
HAVE YOU HEARD ABOUT THE
COOKIE KIT? HAVE A LOOK AT IT.
Leah: WORKING WITH BARBARA
HAS BEEN A DELIGHT.
AND HAVING HER AT OUR BOOTH
IS LIKE HAVING A BUYER MAGNET.
IT'S GREAT.
IF YOU'RE IN THE FOOD BUSINESS,
THIS IS THE SHOW TO BE AT.
Jen: MEETINGS THAT WOULD
TAKE MONTHS TO SCHEDULE
HAPPEN RIGHT AT THE SHOW,
SO WE HAVE THE BUYERS COMING UP,
PLACING ORDERS,
AND LAUNCHING US INTO HUNDREDS
OF STORES RIGHT HERE, RIGHT NOW.
I CAN HAND YOU MY CARD,
AND IF YOU WANT TO,
JUST SHOOT ME AN E-MAIL.
GREAT, AWESOME.
I INVESTED IN PIPCORN
AND SCRATCH & GRAIN
FOR THE SAME REASON.
THEY WERE LED
BY GREAT ENTREPRENEURS.
SINCE I'VE COME ON BOARD,
SCRATCH & GRAIN
HAS OVER $400,000 IN SALES,
AND PIPCORN HAS REACHED
ALMOST $1.4 MILLION.
I'M SO PROUD OF YOU --
AS ALWAYS.
THANK YOU.
BARBARA TRULY IS THE GREATEST
PARTNER WE COULD EVER ASK FOR.
Jeff: SHE'S SMART, SHE KNOWS
EXACTLY WHAT SHE'S DOING,
AND SHE'S WILLING TO
GO ABOVE AND BEYOND TO
HELP US AT ANYTIME.
THE SATISFACTION OF SEEING THEM
COME SO FAR, SO FAST --
LET ME TELL YOU,
IT'S LIKE WATCHING MAGIC.
I'M THE LUCKIEST KID IN TOWN.
"SHARK TANK"
HAS CHANGED OUR LIVES.
WE WENT FROM A LITTLE,
TINY COMPANY
TO A COMPANY
THAT HAS VALUE.
IT HAS DONE MIRACLES
FOR OUR BUSINESS.
♪♪
MY NAME IS JESS SANCHEZ McCLARY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
MY COMPANY IS McCLARY BROS.,
NAMED AFTER MY TWIN
4-YEAR-OLD BOYS, JACK AND BEN.
WELL, I'M GONNA TICKLE YOU!
[ LAUGHING ]
IN 2008, MY HUSBAND AND I
HAD A SMALL PUBLISHING COMPANY
THAT WENT UNDER.
IT WAS DEVASTATING,
AND WE LOST EVERYTHING.
WE EVEN HAD TO MOVE IN
WITH HIS PARENTS.
BUT THE SILVER LINING
WAS THAT IT MOTIVATED ME
TO START McCLARY BROS.
THANK YOU.
WONDERFUL. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
UH-HUH. YOU'RE WELCOME.
THANK YOU.
GROWING MY OWN SMALL BUSINESS
HAS BEEN AN AMAZING EXPERIENCE,
AND IT'S BEEN SUCCESSFUL ENOUGH
THAT MY HUSBAND AND I BOTH
WORK FULL-TIME IN THE BUSINESS.
ALSO, I GET TO HELP
SPUR THE ECONOMY OF DETROIT.
WE MANUFACTURE PRODUCTS HERE,
WE CREATE JOBS HERE,
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO ME TO BE A
POSITIVE PART OF THE COMMUNITY.
KNOCK-KNOCK?
WHO'S THERE?
THIS IS HOW I FEED MY FAMILY,
AND I NEED A DEAL FROM THE
SHARKS SO I CAN GROW MY COMPANY.
FROM THE DAY I STARTED THIS
BUSINESS, I DID IT FOR MY SONS.
I WANT THEM TO BE PROUD
OF WHAT I BUILT FOR THEM
AND OUR COMMUNITY.
♪♪
HI, SHARKS. MY NAME
IS JESS SANCHEZ McCLARY.
AND MY COMPANY IS McCLARY BROS.
AND I'M SEEKING $100,000 IN
EXCHANGE FOR 15% OF MY COMPANY.
TYPICAL DRINK MIXERS ARE LOADED
WITH ARTIFICIAL FLAVORS,
COLORS, AND PRESERVATIVES.
BUT BACK IN THE 1700s,
THAT'S NOT HOW THEY DID IT.
THEY MIXED DRINKS WITH
DRINKING VINEGARS CALLED SHRUBS,
AND THESE COLONIAL-ERA MIXERS
ARE PERFECT
FOR CRAFT-COCKTAIL ENTHUSIASTS
AND INDIVIDUALS LOOKING
FOR A NATURAL ALTERNATIVE
TO TRADITIONAL SODAS.
AND I'M BRINGING
THIS OLD-FASHIONED FAVORITE BACK
AND INTO THE 21st CENTURY.
INTRODUCING McCLARY BROS.'
DRINKING VINEGARS.
OUR DRINKING VINEGARS
ARE MADE WITH ORGANIC,
UNPASTEURIZED
APPLE-CIDER VINEGAR
AND ONLY NATURAL,
ORGANIC INGREDIENTS.
OUR VINEGARS LIVEN UP DRINKS
AND EXCITE THE CONSUMER,
INTRODUCING THEM
TO A VIBRANT, REFRESHING,
NEW FLAVOR EXPERIENCE
THAT WILL CHANGE THE WAY
THEY THINK
OF THAT AGE-OLD STAPLE
AND CLASSIC PRESERVATIVE --
VINEGAR.
NOW, WHO'S THIRSTY?
[ CHUCKLES ]
HIT ME.
♪♪
THANK YOU, SIR.
O'Leary: THANK YOU.
CHEERS!
Greiner: CHEERS.
McClary: THIS ONE HAS
OUR FIG-LEAF DRINKING VINEGAR
AND GIN,
AND IT HAS, ALSO,
SOME CITRUS IN THERE.
I KNOW THERE'S A VARIETY OF --
NOT ENOUGH GIN. [ LAUGHS ]
[ LAUGHTER ]
Herjavec:
I CAN'T TASTE THE ALCOHOL.
[ COUGHS ] ALCOHOL.
ROBERT,
YOU JUST KILLED THAT?
WHOO!
HE'S A THIRSTY MAN.
WE HAVE EXTRAS.
NEXT!
THIS ONE WAS REALLY GOOD.
HOW ABOUT THIS ONE RIGHT HERE?
THIS ONE IS OUR APPLE PIE
WITH BOURBON.
Greiner:
OH, THAT'S VERY GOOD.
YEAH,
THAT'S OUR SIGNATURE FLAVOR.
IT'S VERY GOOD.
CAN WE SEE THE PACKAGING,
SOME OF THE BOTTLES?
THIS IS OUR PINEAPPLE
AND FENNEL-SEED FLAVOR.
ARE THESE THE SAME?
YES, THEY'RE ALL
THE SAME FLAVOR.
♪♪
OH!
IT'S GOOD FOR YOU.
OH, MA!
[ COUGHS ]
WHOA!
JESS, WHAT'S THE BACKSTORY
ON THE PRODUCT?
McClary: SO,
WHEN I STARTED McCLARY BROS.,
I WAS IN CULINARY SCHOOL.
I STARTED DOING SOME RESEARCH,
AND I LIKED THE OLD-FASHIONED
PRESERVATION TECHNIQUES
BECAUSE THEY HAD
REALLY SIMPLE INGREDIENTS,
AND THERE WASN'T A LOT OF
ARTIFICIAL STUFF IN THERE.
AND WHEN I CAME ACROSS
THIS CONCEPT,
IT WAS JUST
A TOTAL LIGHT BULB.
SO, YOU'RE USING VINEGAR
AS THE PRESERVATIVE
INSTEAD OF
ARTIFICIAL PRESERVATIVES.
IS THAT IT?
RIGHT, CORRECT.
I'M NOT SURE AMERICA'S READY FOR
VINEGAR RIGHT AT THE NOSTRIL.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW --
Kutcher: THAT'S NOT TRUE.
I MEAN, THERE ARE,
LIKE, KOMBUCHAS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE
THAT DRINK APPLE-CIDER VINEGAR.
AND I HATE ALL THOSE, TOO.
YEAH, BUT IT DOESN'T --
BUT YOU'RE NOT THE ONLY PALATE.
O'Leary: JESS,
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT I THINK.
SALES CAN PROVE ME WRONG.
WHAT DO YOU GOT IN SALES?
WE HAVE BEEN IN BUSINESS
SINCE 2012,
AND WE HAVE $305,000 IN SALES.
MY WIFE DRINKS VINEGAR...
EVERY DAY.
Greiner: I DO, TOO.
O'Leary: WHY?
IT'S JUST AS A BEVERAGE.
I DO, TOO, BECAUSE IT'S HEALTHY.
SO, EXPLAIN TO ME
WHAT THE HEALTH REASONS ARE.
McClary: STUDIES THAT
HAVE BEEN DONE HAVE SHOWN
IT WILL HELP REDUCE
CHOLESTEROL LEVELS,
AND IT MAY HELP
KEEP BLOOD-SUGAR LEVELS
FROM SPIKING DRAMATICALLY
AFTER A MEAL.
WELL, ARE YOU MARKETING THIS
AS A MIXER,
OR ARE YOU MARKETING IT
AS A BEVERAGE
TO BE DRINKING STRAIGHT?
WELL, WE -- THE WAY WE TRY
TO MARKET IT IS AS A MIXER,
BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
INCREASINGLY
THAT ARE DRINKING IT
AS A NATURAL ALTERNATIVE
TO TRADITIONAL SODAS.
NOW, JESS, HOW ARE YOU
GONNA GROW YOUR SALES?
WHERE DO YOU SEE YOUR GROWTH
COMING FROM?
WELL,
WE'VE JUST NOW STARTED
TO GET INTO
LARGER RESTAURANT CHAINS
THAT ARE LOOKING TO GRAB
THAT HIGHER-MARGIN,
CRAFT-COCKTAIL CUSTOMER
BECAUSE AS CRAFT COCKTAILS
BECOME COOLER,
IT'S HARDER FOR SOME
OF THOSE LARGER CHAINS
TO REALLY KEEP COMPETITIVE.
SO, IT BECOMES
A DIFFERENTIATED TASTE
THAT YOU CAN'T GET MANY PLACES.
RIGHT.
AND YOU'RE TRYING TO BE
THE GO-TO BRAND FOR THAT.
EXACTLY.
O'Leary: BUT CAN YOU ESTIMATE
HOW BIG THIS MARKET IS?
ARE WE TALKING A $500 MILLION,
$300 MILLION, $200 MILLION?
Cuban: NO.
HOW -- HOW BIG?
$10 MILLION MAYBE.
I MEAN --
O'Leary: $10 MILLION?
BUT IF IT BREAKS OUTSIDE
OF VINEGAR, IT CAN GET
REALLY, REALLY BIG.
IT'S HIGH-END MIXERS.
Herjavec:
SO, FOR YOU TO REALLY GROW,
YOU'VE GOT TO GROW
MORE CUSTOMERS.
Cuban: THEY'RE TRYING
TO CREATE A CATEGORY...
O'Leary: I DON'T LIKE THAT.
...HIGH-END VINEGAR MIXERS.
THAT'S REALLY HARD TO DO.
IT'S BEEN REALLY GREAT TRYING
TO MOVE INTO THAT DIRECTION
BECAUSE BARTENDERS LOVE
PLAYING WITH SOMETHING NEW.
Greiner: I DON'T
REALLY DRINK HARD LIQUOR,
SO I'M NOT VERY KNOWLEDGEABLE
IN THE ARENA.
BUT I KNOW ENOUGH
ABOUT THE MEDICINAL PROPERTIES
OF UNPASTEURIZED
CIDER VINEGAR.
I WOULD SEE
IF YOU COULD DO
SOME TYPE OF INDEPENDENT
LABORATORY TESTING
WHERE YOU COULD HAVE MORE TO SAY
ABOUT MIXING THIS WITH ALCOHOL.
MAYBE CALMER STOMACH EXPERIENCE
OR HELPS YOUR DIGESTION.
MM-HMM.
WHATEVER IT IS, I HOPE
THAT YOU CAN FIGURE THAT OUT.
I THINK IT'S DOWN THE ROAD
FOR YOU A LITTLE BIT.
GOOD LUCK TO YOU,
BUT I'M OUT.
♪♪
YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE AT THE ABSOLUTE CRUX
OF A DILEMMA
IN TERMS OF RISK.
AND THAT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS
MOST PEOPLE
DON'T START A BUSINESS.
YOU HAVE
A GOOD BUSINESS.
YOU STARTED SOMETHING
FROM NOTHING.
SO, NOW,
DO YOU TAKE A BUSINESS
THAT'S PUTTING FOOD
ON YOUR TABLE
AND RISK IT FOR THE POTENTIAL OF
GOING INTO SOMETHING MUCH WIDER
THAT WILL REQUIRE MORE MONEY
AND MORE RISK?
I DON'T SEE HOW AN INVESTMENT
TODAY IS GONNA HELP YOU.
AND IN SOME WAYS,
IT MAY ACTUALLY...HURT YOU.
I-I'M OUT.
♪♪
JESS, IT'S A GREAT BRAND.
IT'S A GREAT LOOK.
THANK YOU.
Kutcher: MM-HMM.
IT'S A NICHE THAT YOU OWN,
AND YOU'RE PROFITABLE.
IF YOU COULD START
GETTING MORE MOMENTUM
AND YOU START GETTING IT
A LITTLE BIT WIDER,
I ACTUALLY THINK
YOU CAN PIVOT
AND GROW THIS INTO
A SUBSTANTIAL BUSINESS.
BUT UNLIKE MY WIFE,
I'M NOT A FAN OF VINEGAR DRINKS,
SO I'M OUT.
♪♪
O'Leary: I LOOK AT IT
AND SAY TO MYSELF,
"NOT EVERYBODY LOVES
THE TASTE OF VINEGAR,"
SO THAT
REALLY DIMINISHED.
NOW,
YOU'RE ON YOUR OWN --
DUE TO PASSIONS YOU HAVE
ABOUT THE VINEGAR THING --
ARE TRYING TO
REINTRODUCE SOMETHING
THAT ISN'T A NATURAL
IN TERMS OF PRESERVATION.
IT'S A TASTE.
IT'S A TINY MARKET.
YOU HAVE THE CHALLENGE OF HAVING
TO GO REINVENT THIS CATEGORY
FOR A WHOLE NEW GENERATION
OF PEOPLE WHO AREN'T USED TO IT.
THAT'S REALLY PIONEERING,
AND WHAT OFTEN HAPPENS
TO PIONEERS IS, THEY GET
A LOT OF ARROWS IN THEIR BACK
BECAUSE NOT ONLY
DO YOU HAVE THAT PROBLEM,
YOU ALSO
GOT TO GET DISTRIBUTION.
LET'S BE HONEST
WITH EACH OTHER.
IT'S FOUR GUYS AND A DOG
THAT DRINK THIS STUFF.
AND MAYBE THAT'LL CHANGE,
BUT IT'S REALLY SMALL.
WHY ARE YOU DOING THIS
TO YOURSELF?
HERE'S THE THING.
IT'S VINEGAR.
YOU'RE BELITTLING PEOPLE,
AND THAT'S NOT OKAY.
NO, I'M NOT!
YEAH, YOU ARE!
I'M ASKING A QUESTION,
AND I WANT AN ANSWER.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
SHE GAVE YOU AN ANSWER!
AND I SAID I'M OUT.
AND IF HER ANSWER'S
NOT SUITABLE, THAT'S FINE,
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO
BELITTLE PEOPLE. IT'S NOT COOL.
I'M NOT BELITTLING YOU.
I'M ASKING YOU WHY IT CAN BE BIG
BECAUSE THAT'S THE ONLY
REASON -- EVEN YOU'RE
NOT GONNA INVEST.
YOU KNOW, I'LL TELL YOU
WHY IT COULD BE BIG.
YOU KNOW WHAT I LOVE ABOUT THIS?
I'LL TELL YOU WHY IT COULD BE
BIG. IT COULD BE BIG --
YOU'RE NOT GONNA
WRITE A CHECK, THOUGH.
I THINK THAT WHAT YOU HAVE
IS EXTRAORDINARY PACKAGING.
I THINK THIS IS REALLY,
REALLY BEAUTIFUL.
I THINK
YOU'RE LIMITING YOURSELF
BY STAYING
IN THE VINEGAR/MIXER SPACE,
AND I THINK THAT ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT YOU HAVE TO DO
IS STEP BACK
AND REALLY THINK ABOUT A BROADER
VISION FOR THE COMPANY.
THESE VINEGAR BEVERAGES
ARE STARTING TO TREND.
HOWEVER, AT THIS POINT, I DON'T
THINK THAT YOU HAVE A PLAN
THAT'S BROAD ENOUGH
TO GET BEHIND AS AN INVESTOR.
SO I'M OUT.
♪♪
THANK YOU.
GOOD LUCK.
THANKS SO MUCH.
GOOD LUCK, JESS.
THANK YOU.
GO OUT AND CRUSH IT.
McClary:
I FEEL GOOD ABOUT MY PITCH.
I FEEL GOOD ABOUT
THE CONVERSATION WE HAD.
WE ARE MAKING A PROFIT
EVERY YEAR, SO WE'LL GET THERE.
IT'S JUST GONNA TAKE LONGER
THAN WE WOULD LIKE IT TO.
♪♪
Narrator:
NEXT INTO THE TANK IS A SOLUTION
TO A GROWING
MULTIBILLION-DOLLAR PROBLEM.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS CHRIS GILPIN.
AND I AM THE PRESIDENT
OF SignalVault LLC.
I'M HERE TODAY SEEKING $200,000
FOR 12 1/2% OF MY COMPANY.
SHARKS, I'M SURE WE'VE ALL
RECEIVED THAT PHONE CALL
FROM THE BANK ASKING US
IF WE HAVE OUR DEBIT CARDS
BECAUSE THEY'RE SEEING SOME
"UNUSUAL ACTIVITY" IN TIMBUKTU.
AS AN IDENTITY-THEFT
AND COMPUTER-CRIMES EXPERT,
I CAN TELL YOU THAT HACKERS
CAN BUILD A DEVICE
THAT CAN STEAL YOUR NAME,
CARD NUMBER, EXPIRATION DATE,
AND SECURITY CODE FROM YOUR CARD
WHILE IT'S STILL IN YOUR WALLET
OR PURSE.
IMAGINE I'M A HACKER.
YOU GUYS WOULD ALL BE VULNERABLE
BECAUSE YOU'RE WITHIN RANGE
OF MY SCANNER,
WHICH IS OUTLINED
BY THIS RED TAPE.
THIS WALLET WAS TURNED IN TO
THE "SHARK TANK" LOST AND FOUND,
AND THIS IS A RFID SCANNER
THAT HACKERS CAN PURCHASE ONLINE
FOR AS LITTLE AS $25.
LET'S SEE THE INFORMATION WE CAN
CAPTURE WITH JUST A QUICK SCAN.
[ BEEP ]
OH, MR. CUBAN, I THINK
YOU MAY HAVE DROPPED THIS,
AND THAT IS WHY I DEVELOPED
THE SignalVault CREDIT-
AND DEBIT-CARD PROTECTOR.
AND I'M GONNA SHOW YOU
HOW EASILY
YOU CAN PROTECT YOUR WALLET.
SIMPLY PLACE THE SignalVault
NEAR YOUR CARDS,
AND OUR E-FIELD TECHNOLOGY
MAKES YOUR INFORMATION
INVISIBLE TO HACKERS.
[ BEEP ]
CONTRARY TO OTHER ANTI-HACKING
SOLUTIONS AVAILABLE,
THE SignalVault NEVER NEEDS
CHARGING OR BATTERIES
AND FITS IN ANY WALLET.
SO, SHARKS, I JUST NEED TO KNOW,
WHO WANTS TO HELP ME
PROTECT MILLIONS OF VICTIMS
FROM THE NEXT CROWD-HACK ATTACK?
I HAVE SOME SAMPLES
FOR YOU GUYS.
ARE YOU GONNA GET
YOUR WALLET BACK?
[ LAUGHING ]
ROBERT.
THANK YOU.
Gilpin: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
KEVIN.
THANK YOU.
Herjavec: WHAT IS
THE SignalVault?
IS IT THE CARD?
THE SignalVault
IS THE ACTUAL DEVICE, YES,
AND IT IS A COMBINATION
OF COMPONENTS
THAT BASICALLY MASK
YOUR CREDIT-CARD INFORMATION
FROM ANY TYPE OF SCANNER.
BUT HOW DO I APPLY IT?
YOU WOULD JUST SIMPLY
TAKE THE SignalVault,
AND YOU WOULD ACTUALLY
JUST PLACE THAT IN YOUR WALLET,
NEAR YOUR CARDS.
YOU'VE GOT A CHIP IN HERE.
YES.
AND HOW DOES THE CHIP
GET ACTIVATED?
IT DETECTS A SIGNAL
FROM A SCANNER.
FOR EXAMPLE,
IF SOMEONE WALKS PAST YOU,
AND THAT ACTUALLY POWERS
THE CHIP IN THE SignalVault.
I HAVE A QUESTION.
Cuban: SO, TELL US
ABOUT YOUR BUSINESS.
HOW MANY ARE YOU SELLING?
WHAT'S YOUR REVENUES? ET CETERA.
OKAY, SO, I STARTED THE COMPANY
A YEAR AND NINE MONTHS AGO.
MM-HMM.
AND WE'VE SOLD
ROUGHLY 45,000 OF THEM,
SELLING THEM
MAINLY ON MY WEBSITE.
WHAT DO YOU SELL THEM FOR?
SELL THEM FOR $14.95.
AND WHAT
DO THEY COST YOU?
COST ME 75 CENTS TO MAKE THEM.
MY MAN!
[ LAUGHTER ]
GREAT MARGINS.
Greiner: IT'S A GREAT MARGIN.
TODAY,
YOU'VE SOLD 45,000 CARDS.
SO, WHAT ARE
YOUR TOTAL SALES SO FAR?
RIGHT OVER $300,000.
Kutcher: HOW MUCH MONEY HAVE YOU
INVESTED IN THIS COMPANY?
OKAY, SO, I'VE INVESTED $1
INTO THIS COMPANY.
[ LAUGHS ]
OH, NO. [ LAUGHS ]
OKAY,
AND LET ME EXPLAIN.
WHEN I FIRST HAD THE IDEA
FOR THIS,
I TOLD MY FIANCéE THAT I THOUGHT
I WOULD NEED ABOUT $8,000
TO CREATE THE PROTOTYPE.
AND IN JULY OF 2013,
I PURCHASED A LOTTERY TICKET.
[ LAUGHS ]
I REALIZED I HAD HIT
FIVE OUT OF SIX NUMBERS
IN THE FLORIDA LOTTO,
AND I WON $8,000.
YOU KNOW, AND THAT'S A TEMPLATE
FOR EVERYBODY TO FOLLOW.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WHAT'S THE VOLUME
OF THIS THEFT CURRENTLY?
WELL, WE'RE CURRENTLY SEEING
$8 BILLION IN LOSSES EVERY YEAR
IN THE UNITED STATES.
THE U.S. ACCOUNTS FOR HALF
OF THE CREDIT-
AND DEBIT-CARD FRAUD WORLDWIDE.
WHAT PERCENT
OF MARKET SHARE
DOES YOUR COMPETITOR HAVE
COMPARED TO WHAT YOU HAVE?
I.D. STRONGHOLD
IS THE MONSTER IN THE SPACE.
HE PROBABLY HAS 80%.
TO ME, THIS IS ABOUT GETTING A
BRAND THAT GIVES IT CREDIBILITY.
SO, IN MY SPACE,
I DO MUTUAL FUNDS.
THAT'S ALL
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY
AND COMPLIANCE
WITH REGULATORS AND A BRAND.
IT'S TRUST. PEOPLE TRUST ME.
I'M VERY TRUSTWORTHY.
[ GREINER LAUGHS ]
I LIKE YOUR DEAL, BUT YOU'RE NOT
OFFERING ME ENOUGH.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
200K --
I WOULD DO YOUR DEAL FOR 20%.
AND I'LL ENDORSE
THIS TECHNOLOGY
TO A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO INVEST WITH ME.
Greiner:
LISTEN, CHRIS.
THIS IS WHAT I THINK I COULD DO
IN ONE MONTH ALONE ON QVC
WITH THIS ITEM.
I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE YOU
AN OFFER.
I WOULD LIKE TO
GO 200K FOR 18%.
LORI, I LOVE YOUR OFFER.
UM, I, UH -- I JUST WORKED
REALLY HARD TO GET HERE, AND --
WHAT'S YOUR COUNTER?
UM, I WOULD FIRST LOVE
TO HEAR MAYBE ASHTON OUT.
Kutcher: I'LL CLEAN UP
THE SLATE FOR YOU.
I THINK WHAT YOU HAVE HERE IS
GREAT, BUT I THINK IT'S A RACE.
I THINK YOUR COMPETITOR HAS MOST
OF THE MARKET SHARE RIGHT NOW,
AND THEY PROBABLY
HAVE MORE CAPITAL
TO PUT BEHIND THAT
AND DRIVE IT OUT,
AND SO I'M GONNA STEP
OUT OF THIS.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, ASHTON.
I OFFERED YOU $200,000
FOR 20%.
AND YOU SHOULD TAKE IT.
THE -- THE TROUBLE IS,
THE LONGER I LISTEN,
THE LESS INTERESTED
I'M GETTING,
SO YOU GOT TO MAKE A DECISION
AT SOME POINT.
NO, YOU DON'T.
I AM MAKING MINE 15%
BECAUSE I REALLY LOVE IT...
DISCOUNT BRANDING.
...BUT I REALLY WANT YOU
TO SEE THE VALUE OF ME, AS WELL,
AND I'D LIKE YOU
TO SAY YES.
MY GOAL IS TO JUST MAKE
SignalVault A HOUSEHOLD NAME.
THAT I CAN DO FOR YOU.
[ SIGHS ]
I CAN DO THAT
WITH LIGHTNING SPEED.
I THINK ANY SHARK
CAN DO THAT FOR YOU,
BUT YOU HAVE TO BE WITH A BRAND
THAT MAKES SENSE.
AND I THINK I MADE YOU
A REALLY GOOD OFFER.
I DON'T -- THIS IS TIED
TO FINANCIAL SERVICES.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS.
NO, IT'S NOT.
I'M NOT GONNA --
I'M NOT GONNA DISCOUNT MY DEAL,
BY THE WAY.
THIS IS A CONSUMER PLAY,
AND I'M A CONSUMER PERSON.
I'M GONNA STAY RIGHT
WHERE I AM BECAUSE YOU
GOT TO PAY MORE FOR ME.
I'M SORRY.
Herjavec: CHRIS -- SO, CHRIS,
I'M VERY INTERESTED.
I SEE
AN ENTIRE SECURITY BRAND.
I HAVE A GREAT
SECURITY BRAND.
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER.
♪♪
Narrator:
ONE SHARK IS OUT.
KEVIN AND LORI BOTH HAVE OFFERS
ON THE TABLE
FOR CHRIS' CREDIT-CARD
SECURITY PRODUCT, SignalVault,
BUT INTERNET-SECURITY EXPERT
ROBERT HERJAVEC
IS ALSO INTERESTED.
Herjavec: I SEE
A TWO-PRONG STRATEGY.
I LOVE THE IDEA
OF BEING ON A QVC.
I HAVE A RELATIONSHIP
WITH HSN.
WE'RE TRYING TO BUILD BRANDS
AROUND IT.
I HAVE THE LARGEST
PRIVATELY HELD
ENTERPRISE SECURITY COMPANY
IN THE WORLD RIGHT NOW.
I'LL DO THE $200,000
FOR 15%.
WE'LL GET ON THAT PATH TO
BRING IT INTO THE DATA CENTERS
IN ORDER TO OFFER A BIGGER SER--
IT'S DIFFERENT.
NO, IT'S -- IT'S --
THAT'S WHERE YOU'RE GONNA GO.
YOU NEED TO BLITZ THE MARKET.
YOU NEED TO GO ALL OVER.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
IT'S SO POWERFUL TO BE
ON QVC WITH TONS OF --
THIS IS -- THIS IS MILES AWAY
FROM LORI'S BRAND.
ROBERT HAS A CREDIBLE
BRANDING ON THIS --
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING HERE?
BUT, FRANKLY, IN FINANCIAL
SERVICES, I'M THE KING.
YOU SHOULD NOT
EVEN BE TALKING.
NO, I SHOULD BE BECAUSE YOUR
DEAL'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN, LORI.
THAT'S RIDICULOUS!
I SMELL THE DEATH OF YOUR DEAL.
I -- NO.
I CAN TELL THAT
HE SEES THE MERIT OF ME.
NOT REALLY.
AND, WAIT, I'M GONNA TELL YOU.
ALLSTATE AND STATE FARM, I'M --
YES. YES, LORI,
'CAUSE HE CAN SEE
HOW THIS IS RELATED
TO A LIPSTICK BOX.
MY GOD!
I GET THAT I'M COMPETING
WITH ROBERT.
HE'S OUR ONLINE SECURITY EXPERT
FOR ENTERPRISE,
BUT I HAVE TO BE GIVEN
SOME CREDIT
FOR THE FINANCIAL-SERVICES BRAND
I HAVE IN AMERICA.
I'M THE ONLY GUY THAT ACTUALLY
SELLS TO CONSUMERS RIGHT NOW
UNDER MY OWN NAME.
THAT'S WHY MY BRAND WORKS.
SO I'D LOOK AT THIS AND SAY...
I SELL TO CONSUMERS
UNDER MY OWN NAME, TOO.
...YOU SHOULD SERIOUSLY
CONSIDER WHAT I'M OFFERING YOU.
I'M SERIOUSLY CONSIDERING
EVERY OFFER.
IT'S $200,000 FOR 20%.
Greiner: WELL, ANYWAY,
TO FINISH WHAT I WAS SAYING
WHEN I WAS SO RUDELY
INTERRUPTED --
ALL RIGHT,
YOU HAVE $200,000 FOR 15%,
$200,000 FOR 15%,
$200,000...
15%.
...FOR 20%.
YEAH.
AND?
Cuban: AND PLUS, LOOK,
WHAT I'VE SEEN IN MY EXPERIENCE
IS THAT COMPANIES THAT COME OUT
WITH A CONSUMER PRODUCT
AND THINK THEIR MONEY
IS GONNA BE MADE IN ENTERPRISE
DON'T REALIZE HOW EXPENSIVE
AND HOW LONG IT TAKES.
AND SO I THINK
YOU'RE UNDER-PLAYING
JUST HOW DIFFICULT
THAT WILL BE.
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
Greiner: YOU HAVE
SUCH A SIMPLE PRODUCT
THAT YOU COULD HAVE PEOPLE
OUT IN FORCE SELLING IT.
YES.
YOU COULD HAVE QVC,
BED BATH & BEYOND,
TARGET,
ALL THE DIFFERENT RETAILERS.
YOU COULD HAVE
YOUR ONLINE.
YOU COULD HAVE PROMOTIONS.
YES.
YOU COULD GO
TO INSURANCE COMPANIES.
AND EVERY SHARK
CAN DO THAT FOR YOU.
YOU COULD DO IT ALL.
WE ALL DO IT.
BUT -- BUT I WILL DO IT
THE BEST.
CHRIS,
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
ROBERT, YOU ARE DEFINITELY
ONE OF THE SHARKS
THAT I WANTED TO WORK WITH.
AND, LORI, OF COURSE,
YOUR CONNECTIONS WITH QVC ARE --
ARE, YOU KNOW...
YOU CAN'T PUT A PRICE ON THAT.
I WOULD LOVE FOR YOU GUYS
TO WORK TOGETHER.
IF YOU GOT TWO SHARKS,
WHAT'S YOUR COUNTER?
MY COUNTER IS...
♪♪
...$250,000
FOR YOUR INITIAL 18%.
[ SCOFFS ]
WHOA.
CHRIS,
IF YOU WANT US BOTH,
YOU NEED TO OFFER BACK
BETTER EQUITY THAN 18%.
Herjavec: THERE'S GONNA BE
A LOT OF WORK.
THIS IS WHAT OUR TEAM DOES.
I THINK WE'RE WORTH IT.
I'M -- I'M WILLING
TO DO THAT.
I-I'M DEFINITELY WILLING
TO ADD --
WHAT IS -- WHAT IS THE EQUITY
THAT YOU WOULD GO UP TO?
I WILL DO...
$200,000 FOR 25%,
BOTH OF YOU.
I'LL DO IT. WILL YOU?
I'M IN. DONE.
YAY! I LOVE IT!
DON'T BE SO NERVOUS!
[ LAUGHS ]
Greiner: I LOVE IT.
WE'RE GONNA
BLOW THIS OUT.
GO CELEBRATE.
THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS, MAN.
GOOD LUCK.
CONGRATULATIONS, CHRIS.
YES!
STRIKING A DEAL
WITH ROBERT AND LORI --
THEY ARE MY DREAM SHARKS.
I KNOW THAT WE ARE DESTINED
FOR HUGE THINGS.